this is worse than i thought if you guys
think this is my mess prove it in a
court of law
you guys are just looking for a
scapegoat
[Music]
yeah
how many days did you spend last year
cleaning up the camera at least five
days no no honestly at least five days
at least five days you stood in the
middle of that room and it was perfectly
organized let's go in there right now
and see if it looks anything like how it
did at the beginning of last year
whoa
what is this stuff like what are those
dirty bags what is this there's a box
for allen
you know about halfway through the year
last year i kind of just was like you
know what i'm gonna have a panic attack
if i actually invest myself in this room
clean clean it up clean clean clean it
just gets nerdy i had to quit i had to
quit this looks like some nico perfect
camera stuff right here who knows what
this is remember how he said if anyone
puts anything on this table they get
what was it like knuckles the drill the
if you release thing on this table
you get a quick stir number the drill
the drill
oh dude it hurts so bad it hurts it
hurts so bad do it to me so i can see
how bad it hurts okay let me get the
drill going
that's just the taste just like just a
taste that's awful it's horrible it's
just like five percent that's five
percent but whoever left stuff on this
table that's at least eighty percent i
have to plug it into the wall look i'm
in the same boat with you guys i like
putting my gear away i like keeping it
nice and organized the gear belongs in a
case if it has a case nico has a
different attitude about that we all
know punishments are being dished out we
need to go get some sternum rubs where's
niko
i think a good five seconds is
that that will kill a man there's a hole
in the box now
let's just take a look at the camera
room i have nothing to hide look you
left that camera equipment out for
months
and it led to this situation i didn't do
it who did it then the corruption
started with you sir that's your rig you
have any proof what do you mean proof
that's your rig this is not my
configuration
this is a circus this is a circus no no
no no no no nico it's yours these are
not my pizzas you guys are just looking
for a scapegoat [ __ ] look look
if you guys
think this is my mess
prove it
in a court of law
nico you don't want to go there man
you realize punishment is double
100 100 drill for five seconds jake
would you be my prosecuting lawyer
absolutely there's nothing even to
prosecute this is open and shut up
hi is this wesley and wesley
incorporated
we are wesley and wesley incorporated a
lot of people don't know that jake's
middle name is wesley i'm in need of
legal representation
to make sure that's conflict of interest
wesley that is conflict of interest
right there you can't do that you can't
defend him i will defend
you you realize if you do this your your
business is through you're done our
partnership is over if you do this
wesley you don't ruin what you have hey
hey hey hey
oh you're up
boom that's what i like i'll see you
guys in court
when's court after lunch
i don't know how does this work yeah
after lunch after lunch
guys no one go in the camera room it's
basically a crime scene do not go in
there do not touch anything it's sealed
off until further notice thank you
issue
rule analysis conclusion the analysis is
the analysis of the facts
i'm innocent tell me more what they're
trying to peg me on is when i built my
perfect camera the thing is i put all
the equipment away here is the gear we
found on the table here is this man
using that exact same gear the thing is
we have video proof of what those rigs
look like currently none of the rigs on
those tables look like the rigs from the
perfect camera videos therefore they
can't be from the perfect camera we also
have the sound kit which i know nico
used on his last production after we
were in texas if we look at a schedule
of when things were shot sam has shot
two films since i shot my film he shot
tiny guns and he shot the black rifle
cops in texas and i represent everyone
that wasn't in texas
this is worse than i thought
look at these bags this test is dead
justice isn't about punishing people
because you don't like them justice is
about truth it doesn't matter who you
are no one's above the law seems like
they're trying to divert attention away
he's whipping everybody into our friends
they just create a mob here and distract
people from the real real criminal in
this situation and who is that
this could be a tough case there's a lot
of evidence piling up against our
defendant here nico his perfect camera
rig so to speak that created a huge
disaster in the camera room maybe has
something to do with this perfect camera
you know what i mean maybe this perfect
camera
begets some sort of chaos and calamity
or like it drives people insane once
they find that perfect camera
something just goes off in their brain
in their mind that sets them off on a
destructive path
[Music]
he's in the evidence room he's being
placed under arrest sir at this very
moment i'm going to sue the city for
everything you got yeah classic
nico we're not from the city we're from
corridor
did i just get some batteries please
it's a crime scene matt get out of here
matt you committed crimes this is a
farce come on
we are here to judge the case of nico
perringer the defendant charged with uh
what is he charged with again charged
with one count of failing to put back
items where they belong wes what you got
in that briefcase is that evidence none
of your business i never thought you'd
betray me like this i never thought
you'd betray me like this uh how may i
refer to each of you you can refer to me
as wesleyan wesley and yep
the prosecution may lead with their
opening statements are you guys done
with your charade and circus you can't
talk in charades and we're clearly
talking or i'll have you ejected from my
cord your honor
uh gentlemen of the jury what we bring
before you today is a very simple case
you see this man right here can i see
that can i say it's my turn to talk to
my opening argument now this man set out
to have a room cleaned the room went to
hell i think honestly like most
criminals they think they didn't do it
the defense is going to convolute this
make it seem all complicated it's all
actually a lot simpler the truth of the
matter is that he did do it and he will
face justice for it
the
defense may now present their opening
statements thank you judge
of course
gentlemen and gentleman of the jury
i come to for you as a humble man a
single man
a young man
my client nico over here is completely
innocent and i plan to prove that
jake aka wesley from a former
arrangement i used to have he has
pointed out the fact that at the
beginning of the year nico
took responsibility
of
said room we were all five years old at
one point correct five years old until
about right now
that's safe to say and in that time
we change
we evolve and in that year
we have changed and we have evolved i am
going with the defense of change
nico
you have changed
i'm going to leave it right there
sir gorski your honor
i have something in here that i would
like to give you
this is not a gift nor a bribe are you
submitting
so we got some solid evidence on the
prosecution's behalf here present your
first witness the prosecution calls mr
wren wikeman to the stand beautiful
ren ren wyman
yes what do you have in your pocket my
hand
good do you remember the camera room
looking like that it did look like this
mr perringer made a perfect camera rig
that involved
this here
camera mount that's absolutely part
of nico's perfect camera rig do you
recognize these photos as being part of
nico's camera rig i would recognize that
face anywhere and do you recognize the
quick release tripod plate as the same
that is in those photos it's like a
carbon copy here is a photo taken from
this morning that has
that exact tripod plate misplaced and
left out on what was once formerly it is
the same
[Applause]
that's all sorted out now yeah may cross
examine the witness no i'm not done with
evidence i can't wait for more evidence
now i'll present the rest of my case to
you your owner
the sound box your honor this is the
quarter sound box from the time of the
cleaning
sound box
currently as it was found in evidence
this morning
that man over there was the last person
to go on a production to use this sound
box
and this is how we found it today long
story short that man over there left
gear out all over the place and you went
from a situation like this your honor a
camera station perfectly clean
to a camera station
junky and mean
all right thank you
[Applause]
uh wesley and i'd like to thank jake for
that level of bs objection your honor
derogatory objective denied deny is that
bullish bs is not derogatory i'm gonna
go and take this
piece of evidence one more time this
right here seems like it's evidence
that's been tampered with
gentlemen if you guys please take a look
at it does this look like that
piece of rigmarole no
i don't think so objection your honor
objection deny i'd like to see where
this one's heading
look at that does this look like we'd
film something nico being an expert
filmmaker does it look like he would
film with this
my client used two hands
not one hand
the defendant does have in fact
i'd like to call my client nico to the
stand he can't plead the fifth if he
takes the stand
nico
how many projects have you directed shot
i've tracked the two projects two
projects this year and your business
partner the honorable sam gorski how
many projects have sea shot this year
five
five
projects
that means scientifically he's been in
that room more times than you
okay okay i think we're getting
someplace here i like to bring this
sound equipment up we had a lot of oohs
and eyes
because equipment's missing do you also
notice the residue that's on this box
it smells like
texas
and nico was not in texas thank you
gentlemen for your time i appreciate
each and every one of you honorable
gorsky
i love you sir i know i rest my case
gentlemen the jury the defense presents
the case that the sound box there's
texas dirt on it nico we went to texas
uh was it prior to november 14th when
you shot the u-monster project
it was it was
ah
and so it'd be perfectly reasonable that
there would be texas dirt on it we all
know that your shoot took place after we
returned and the halo shoot which used
that sound gear happened afterwards
that's that's irrelevant to this trial
sir
when we returned from texas with the
texas dirt on the sound box the gear was
in there we also get to the issue of the
server table rules when you were just
asked you said uh those drives are part
of server business
there is a video at which 8 43 mrs
barringer says anything on that table
will result in a light sternum rub now
if all the circumstantial evidence that
i've presented doesn't convince you mr
perringer are you or are you not one of
the partners and directors of the
company corridor digital i am outside of
the circumstantial evidence points
directly to you sir it would also be
your responsibility as one of the
partners and directors of the company to
ensure that order is followed and cared
for
and accommodated for so ultimately
regardless of whose hands or on which
equipment it is ultimately your
responsibility to look after these
things i'll leave you with that yeah
thank you we will proceed with our
closing arguments
in closing your honor
guys
i just want to say thank you
thank you for believing in
this innocent man right now
um
i'd like to thank you guys for your time
today
um and as a token of your honor our
appreciation your honor
hold on
objection denied i i i want to see where
this is heading defensive bribery i'm
not offering this
all i'm saying is my client paid me
great money
to defend him and if you guys are here
to defend him as well there may be some
gifts on your car not from me i'm just
saying in first bribery i am not saying
it's for me objection denied i said i'm
curious to see where this is where this
is going your honor
and i rest my case
closing
statement mr watson the defense talks of
honesty
a talk of
humility
and yet
all around you what do you see
accusations the denial of responsibility
he even comes to you guys and he says
you'll
defend this man you're not here to
defend this man you're not here to
prosecute this man what you're here to
do
is to seek the truth
what do you say
[Applause]
that was
gonna break court to let the jury
deliberate on the matters and they shall
return with a verdict
i think at the end of the day
money talk
let's define bribery all right i'm
feeling like i got the best goddamn
lawyer on the planet i'm a little
worried about the judge in this case
potentially being the true
mastermind behind the scenes
man how deep does this rather whole goal
so are you guys decided so okay please
wait here
all right
all right all right
all right let's begin wesley from wesley
and wesley incorporated uh we find you
guilty of perjury and bribery and i
sense you to be disbarred
it's better than i could have hoped
that's how we're starting things off
bribery you're the only one with money
around here that's fantastic get this
out of my face all right on to the
verdict for the defendant nico
p
on the first charge of conspiracy to not
clean the camera room we find you guilty
of conspiracy to not clean the camera
oh yeah oh yeah now on to sentencing um
i sentence you to five seconds of
sternum rubbing but i sentence you to
five seconds of a strong sternum rub
however
after the first two seconds upon good
behavior you will be able to forfeit and
avoid the remaining three seconds
[Music]
if he has good behavior
he will be released from the remaining
three this is a kangaroo court this is a
kangaroo court
and here we go
today justice prevails please restrain
nico for his first
let him keep the year one you're going
to jail for bribery my friend
remember he's putting me in jail
are you ready
stop stop stop that was two seconds that
was 17
half a second and that was not gonna be
all right you have another second and a
half go
now
how are you feeling after those two
seconds was that enough yeah that was
enough you learned your lesson no this
is corrupt it's [ __ ]
wait are you telling me that you are not
in good behavior i'll leave it up to you
your honor oh wow he's quite defiant uh
[Music]
one more yeah he needs it one more
second
come on come on i'm not going easy
anymore he's not a good behavior
he's not on good behavior through the
armor through the armor
all right you're good you're released
you're released he's good he's changed i
can tell
[Music]
hey
i think personally you did great out
there i think i did great as well i know
you have some bribery time to serve that
that is what it is but there used to be
a firm called wesley and wesley
incorporated and at that firm
he'll always be a partner i'll even put
your name first
like
wesley and wesley incorporated with my
name first
[Music]
wesley was incorporated
well here i am a new man or am i anyways
i just want to say this whole court
wouldn't have been possible if it
weren't for our patrons in a way they're
bribing us all so i want to start off by
thinking glitch cube and not a canadian
spy for always having my back regardless
of whether i'm guilty or innocent
and of course alan almanza and phillip
oxford
skinky snack
thank you
harris regepatic and jack o'connell
thanks for supporting us
huge thanks to bobby hansel and alex
duckworm
jordan nick nolte abdullah saleh thanks
for believing in my case and if you
believe in our case here
go to patreon.com corridor digital and
consider supporting us we've got
something really special coming up at
the five dollar tier so stay tuned for
that
[Music]